I'd like to start today by talking about
an aspect of the Trump pardon parade and
the Trump Russia investigation that's
not really being discussed too much
which is the difference between state
and federal crimes okay the background
on Trump pardons actually dates back at
this point what has it been about a
month or so when Donald Trump tweeted in
late July about pardons while we all
agree while all agree the US president
has the complete power to pardon why
think of that when only crime so far is
leaks against us fake news and this is
all in the context of could trump pardon
himself if there were to be federal
charges related to Trump Russia
collusion could trump pardon his kids
could there be pre-emptive pardons
whatever right and clearly Donald Trump
believes he could pardon whoever he
wants whenever he wants whatever the
really important element here is that
Donald Trump's pardon power does not
apply it does not extend to state crimes
now you might be saying okay but let's
see
you've got Robert Moeller at the federal
level investigating Donald Trump why
does it matter whether Trump's pardon
power extends to state crimes it matters
because the entire Trump Russia scandal
is pointing more and more in the
direction of looking at financial crimes
many of which weed many of which would
be at state levels and that would be in
addition to whatever possible federal
crimes we we see or we don't ever see or
whatever right we don't know what's
going to happen so one example to to
make this a little bit more specific
Politico and the Washington Post have
reported and confirmed that New York
Attorney General Eric Schneiderman is
working with Robert Moeller's special
investigation into Trump Russia looking
at financial transactions and Paul
Manafort Trump's former campaign
chairman who is endlessly connected to
Russian money Erik Schneiderman's mere
involvement here already signals that if
there is something there we are looking
at state crimes and Trump's pardon power
is it's totally flaccid right it's
impotent when it comes to stay
crimes to all the constitutional
conservatives who for some crazy reason
support Trump the Constitution in
article 2 section 2 says that the
president's quote power to grant
reprieves and pardons only covers
offenses against the United States in
Constitution speak which I would assume
any constitutional trumpet would be very
familiar with because they're all
experts in the Constitution in legal
terms when we talk about offenses
against the United States is written
about in the Constitution that means
federal crimes it seems like pardons
when it comes to federal crimes is
pretty open-ended when it comes to the
president's powers because there's just
so such little written about it in
statutes and in the Constitution itself
so we're unclear as if the president can
even pardon himself at this point and
actually President Trump can pardon
someone in a tweet I mean he can't he
can't ban transgendered individuals from
the military in a tweet but apparently
he could pardon anyone he wants just by
going to Twitter is that true yeah and
and yet he can't do it for state crimes
that is very very clear what we have
clarity on is that for state crimes it's
just not going to happen and of course
oh it's so unfair no one has ever had a
constitution be as unfair to them as our
Constitution is to me why can't I pardon
state crimes it's so fake and phony Fox
News thinks I should be able to pardon
state crimes my generals think I should
be able to pardon state crimes baron who
does incredible things with computers
he's got an iPad it's amazing he thinks
I should be able to pardon state crimes
states rights nobody talks about states
rights anymore do you think Trump knows
this now think in his back pocket has a
plan that he can just pardon whoever he
wants to if this Trump Russia
investigation comes to a head well or
has he not even found this out yet I
think that it's increasingly clear that
Trump is not playing four dimensional
chess Moeller is the one playing four
dimensional chess or maybe it's more
like Muller is playing chess and Trump
and everyone around him is just
overturning the chessboard in a fit of
childish rage Mulder is not stupid
right so whatever Trump knows and you
know as you're proposing trying to think
about what might Trump know I have no
idea what Trump knows but there
no doubt that the recent pardon of Joe
Arpaio it's a pretty damn clear signal
from Trump that he will use his power to
pardon pretty indiscriminately and
anywhere that he can so if you Robert
Muller and you see that you say well I
will simultaneously explore state-level
crimes in conjunction with state
attorneys general while I do my federal
investigation he's sort of already
working to prevent a blanket pardon
against all possible charges by starting
to involve States Trump has been sending
signals to a lot of people as long as
you don't sell me out I will pardon you
even there's a report actually that
Michael Flynn has been told and when I
say told it's not clear how directly or
whether this happened through a back
channel or whatever but that it's been
communicated to Michael Flynn that if he
stays strong throughout whatever is
going on with him Trump will pardon him
so yeah he may well if we think about
who's most likely doing time for what
happened I think at the top of the list
would be Michael Flynn Paul Manafort and
what Carter Paige or Jared Kushner I
don't know the idea that trumps get a
pardon them and knowing this could
really mess up the investigation for
Robert Mulder so he if we believe what's
going on is being very clever by
involving state attorneys general in
these investigations well you might
think that David there would be so much
backlash if he was departed Michael
Flynn or Carter Page or Paul Manafort
that has that prevented him doing
anything else in the past as you know
maybe the repercussions would be that he
has to go to Congress and explain the
pardons if it was at a federal level
that the crimes made I don't even know
he'd have to but I don't think he would
care we when we started hearing a few
rumblings about oh is Trump going to
fire rod Rosenstein or will he try to
fire mole or whether or not he's
actually legally able to or whatever
oh no he would never do it because the
optics would be so terrible the guy went
to a hurricane relief site praised the
size of the crowd and didn't mention nor
meet with a single one of the victims so
this is not exactly the guy who's
hampered by the optics of what he does
he
just pardon joe arpaio even though that
his lawyers wasn't even in requesting it
it's if we we cannot predict anything if
part of the prediction is based on it
wouldn't look good for Trump because
clearly that is not something that is
hampered any single thing that he has
done we've got such a fantastic program
for you today you know because we had
the two-week vacation we missed audience
questions for several weeks we miss live
calls for several weeks and I anticipate
that we are going to have a fully loaded
series of phone lines for live calls
which are coming up next followed by
audience questions and then we've got a
great bonus show so it's a packed show
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman you can
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show and we'll be back right
after this I'm thrilled that today's
program is supported by tag adapt the
hosting specialists offering whatever
type of hosting package is good for your
business or project this includes
dedicated and virtual private server
solutions cloud server options which are
increasingly popular as well as custom
server solutions taga DAB's web hosting
services support a really broad range of
customers and businesses around the
world and this includes bloggers tech
startups traders and finance gamers web
developers really whatever you can think
of and you can scale their cloud servers
up or down to meet the particular needs
of your business and to also cut costs
by only paying for what you use you can
save twenty British pounds a little over
twenty US dollars on cloud server
options by going to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and using the coupon code
TDPS
20 that's sign up ta ga da be calm /td
PS the discount code all one word all
lowercase
TD PS 20 check it out